after bringing you our first look at
overhyped games it ended up being
terrible we went through your comments
and suggestions you gave us even more
potentially great titles that came
crashing into stores on a wave of hype
and left us disappointed just like your
favorite video game franchises we were
bound to return with the sequel slender
the arrival Slender Man is one of the
most celebrated horror game characters
on the Internet
the villain set the standard for
horrifying online mythologies before
those animal robot suits of five nights
at freddys even thought about scaring
your socks off you'd think that with all
the Slender Man buzz and the occasional
real-life stabbing in his name any game
starring the message board monster would
have to be worthwhile
instead Slenderman the arrival tries to
skate by on a creepy atmosphere and an
occasionally spooky bad guy
the gameplay is simplified to collecting
note pages and turning on generators
while avoiding the creeps stalking you
the game's main villain occasionally
teleports around and can be seen staring
at you in the distance until he appears
nearby and jump scares you and that's
about it
at least the game helped inspire
releases like alien isolation but
slender the arrival was way too
overhyped to justify its underwhelming
premise fable 3 following the footsteps
of its predecessors fable three's
expansive world was filled with charm
but that doesn't necessarily save it
from its obvious shortcomings
most of the game's familiar RPG aspects
were tossed out the window for the sake
of making things easier for the casual
gamer worse the gameplay was plagued
with more bugs in the streetwalkers and
bower stone even with an all-star voice
cast featuring Simon Pegg and Michael
Fassbender fable three's technical
problems and simplified gameplay hamper
any potential enjoyment even a game's
final scenario makes you defend the
entire country from invasion using money
and it's no easy sum to attain if you
play the game properly
this ends things with an unsatisfying
letdown for those who cleared the fable
trilogy with no future installments in
sight
the order 1886 in spite of its cinematic
look creative weapons and unique story
the order 1886 is generic gameplay
didn't end up being Sony's answer to
Gears of War despite early expectations
it's another case of visuals getting
prioritized over gameplay it doesn't
help that the story is linear it offers
no replay value making it feel like a
rental at best or worse an extended
PlayStation demo there are too many
QuickTime events to make you ever feel
like you're in control of anything
meaningful
despite werewolves Zeppelin's Tesla
powered weapons and great graphics
there's not much else here once promised
to be a huge system seller for the
PlayStation 4 the order just ended up
being short for board or another game
because this one sucks
sonic boom rise of lyric after the
fiasco of 2006 is Sonic the Hedgehog we
thought Sega would never be able to
bring Sonic back to proper form for
2014's rise of lyric Sega completely
redesigned the Sonic crew giving them
lankier limbs useless athletic tape
random fashion accessories and possibly
steroids ultimately rise of lyric boils
down to what we were dreading the most
another lousy 3d Sonic game even with a
successful TV series to help build up
the revamped Sonic squad rise of lyric
falls on its face many of the game
segments are hampered by an extremely
basic combat system there's also a weird
laser called enter beam that shoehorned
into the game way too many times in an
era where mario successfully made the
jump to 3d multiple times we're afraid
this is going to be the final nail in
the sonic coffin Sega should just sell
the rights in Nintendo already Tony Hawk
pro skater 5 we had high hopes that
returning to the pro skater series would
mean we'd finally get a good
skateboarding game again but we were
wrong after developer Neversoft left the
Tony Hawk franchise Robo moto took over
in 2010 producing games so bad that the
whole franchise was put on hold
somehow Robo moto reclaimed the reins
for pro skater 5 along with co developer
disruptive games but adding another
studio didn't make the game any better
first Gator 5 is filled with
embarrassing glitches outdated visuals
terrible controls erratic obstacle
clipping and
by her gameplay the game's marketing was
entirely based on the franchise name and
professional boarders featured on the
roster but you'll have more fun just
watching other gamers show off its
endless bugs on YouTube Pro Skater 5 is
easily the worst game of the series and
a blatant attempt to cash in on the
memories of a once beloved series Star
Wars Battlefront even though it had all
the ingredients of a great game Star
Wars Battlefront ultimately failed to
deliver given developer dices history
with the successful battlefield series
fans expected multiplayer goodness on
the same level as battlefield 4 throw in
the Star Wars Battlefront franchise and
we were bound for something both nerdy
and groundbreaking right battlefront
ended up being all sizzle and no steak
it's easily one of the greatest looking
first-person shooters ever made but it's
also one of the shallowest thousands of
players voiced their unhappiness with
the GAE resulting in lukewarm scores on
Metacritic and elsewhere excluding the
tutorials almost all of battlefront
focuses on online multiplayer despite a
collection of familiar multiplayer modes
everything just boils down to the same
kind of mid-range firefight which can
get old fast
after playing battlefront for 30 minutes
you've pretty much experienced all the
game has to offer
this game has a shorter life than one of
Jabba's dancers Assassin's Creed unity
despite being a perfect opportunity for
Ubisoft to push modern consoles to their
limits Assassin's Creed unity ended up
offering more of the same kind of stuff
that we saw with the franchise back in
2007 it doesn't have the awesome pirate
motif of Black Flag and the French
Revolution back trap gets pretty
stagnant while it's cool to see
thousands of revolting citizens on the
streets
it's underwhelming to watch the same
thing happening down every city block if
that weren't bad enough unity has made
much much worse because of its numerous
technical issues seriously it has a ton
of glitches no seriously so many
glitches some of these bugs are simple
visual stutters but there's much worse a
glitch where the faces the characters
don't show up at their hair eyes and
teeth do it's as frightening as you'd
imagine still nothing beats having the
game glitch just before your big
assassination attempt on a high-profile
target did you be soft to lay the sequel
because of these issues of course not
Assassin's Creed syndicate launched less
than a year later
watch dogs watch dogs was one of the
most highly anticipated launch games for
the ps4 and Xbox one but it simply
failed to deliver sure gamers could hack
their way through an open-world version
of Chicago but after playing for a few
hours nobody really wanted to a lot of
the fundamental elements of watchdogs
simply aren't that good
crappy controls vehicles that handle
like a tractor trailer hovercraft no
matter what you're driving and that's a
major problem given how much driving you
have to do also it's filled with tons of
repetitive side missions so let's see
poor controls horrible driving and
crappy stealth sequences watchdogs
probably should have been sent to
obedience school answer the matrix
remember how amazing that first Matrix
movie was well the video game that came
afterwards Enter the Matrix is where
hope goes to die the title was a tie-in
with the release of the first movie
sequel The Matrix Reloaded which
received similarly mixed reactions from
fans and critics as a result Enter the
Matrix was rushed to launch the same
week that the film hit theaters and it
shows any game said in the world of The
Matrix comes with some pretty simple
expectations among them being able to
play as the movies heroes like neo
Morpheus or Trinity while fighting with
stylized moves and slow down action
sequences you know all the stuff that
made people like the movie in the first
place instead you end up playing as
Niobe or ghost too insignificant
characters from reloaded the
third-person fighting had a lot of
promise especially when you factor in
your bullet-time abilities but it gets
old quickly sure it was kind of
interesting that Enter the Matrix help
tell the side stories of what happened
around the events of reloaded too bad
reloaded wasn't much better than a
crummy video game on its own thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which hyped-up games you
think were the absolute worst